So thanks for coming. I really
appreciate you my first time at Google.
It's kind of overwhelming. Really. Yeah,
I had imagined, but you know, Pixar,
you like a postage stamp.
This is like a country. Uh,
the city of mountain view
was very generous to us. So
most of the time. Um, yeah.
So thanks to cliff for arranging this and,
and the authors program and thanks to
Disney for bringing you out and arranging
the clips and stuff. Um, oh, that's, no,
that's the guy who's the Mars rover guy.
Really? Yeah. So you should tie that I've
talked to you. Yeah. So, uh, John Carter,
John Carter. So I actually would like to
start in the will drive ab people nuts.
I'd love to have the concept art from
when you were, how old were you? Uh,
it was a 11. You're 11 years old.
Perishing draftsmen skill. So this is you.
This is you here or it's me.
So you were 11. I was 11.
And then I think if there's
another one there that's a,
that's Mark Andrews at age 10.
Look how good he could draw.
And he really kicked it.
But I hate him. It's, um,
and then I think also you have a
Michael Shay bond froze nine. Yeah.
Putting himself that's a little bit
more accurate for nine years old. Yeah.
I'm like his,
his foot robot.
The one thing come between all three
of us besides that we all wrote on this
picture was that we all were infected by
the book that this movie came from, uh,
called a princess of Mars.
And we'd all read it similar ages and
all couldn't sort of drop the images and
um, and characters that stuck in our
heads as we grow, grew older. I mean,
we all have things that sticking
our heads in the formative years,
whether it's an album we've heard or
movie we've seen or a book we've read.
And this was one of them.
Yeah.
So we said we had to have a little
club once we found this out.
We didn't know this until we were all
writing really. And we said we should, oh,
now that we have to make it,
like if any other writer comes on this
at the right half to have a drawing
improve that they like read this book
when they were a kid. That's really, yeah.
I didn't discover burrows
until much later. Fortunately.
No, I couldn't. Like I, I,
I'm actually, I shouldn't even
be on this day. Um, but it's, uh,
it's interesting cause you know,
1917 and I just haven't seen was
when it was published, compiled,
but it was, we actually started 1912
was when he started in copyright.
I might point you exactly.
And so it, uh, it's,
it's literally a hundred years to last
month. Wow. That's pretty amazing. So,
so this brings up the question of
an anachronism, right? So, you know,
people are like, well, he gleefully
embracing anachronisms the book.
So what did you think about this? Did
you ever hit a point where you're like,
well, it's just not Mars enough,
it's just not real enough? You know,
there's this weird assumption
that
you have to modernize,
contemporize or bring, I mean,
I made a movie about fish that talk
underwater that was inaccurate.
I find that if you have a problem
with me taking license with Mars,
then it's a sad world.
You live in that you can't take license
and have stories where you take a couple
of things. You mean Grimms fairy
tales have like, there was a sausage,
a burden of mouse and they lived in a
house together and you're like, okay.
You know what I mean?
It's, it's, it's a, it's,
that's just the fun of stories is taking
a couple of things are one thing and
just going, what if, and that's
what Burroughs did. You know,
that was the period of time
when telescopes had just
gotten slightly improved
and they could see a little bit
better on the surface of Mars.
And they saw these lines and some people,
you know,
I think it was personal low that just
thought that they were canals and it got
everybody thinking about
maybe people live there.
And then you just see
this plethora of, of, uh,
just fantasizing.
And imagination go on that
didn't have a title to it yet,
but it wasn't until the 30s or forties
that they started calling it science
fiction in a sort of,
you know,
common way that we do not denigrating
way back then. It was still horrible.
Yeah. Pulp. But the
interesting thing is that I,
the thing that I loved about the book
and what we felt was the DNA about it,
the theme,
the thumb print about it to capitalize
on that hadn't been done by anybody.
Even though it's inspired so many things.
Yeah.
Was that it felt like
a romantic adventure.
It felt like somebody that just wanted
to explore and find one more last
continent on our planet.
It didn't read like somebody that wanted
to travel in a spaceship and go to
space. It was almost
against his will. He's like,
I have nowhere else I can uncover.
The guy got to go off the planet.
But it was like, it was sort of
like a reluctant choice in it,
but it was really this sense of desire
to, to explore, find a new culture,
find a new war,
um,
civilization that had been going on in
parallel the whole time that we just
didn't know about, which had been
happening for a hundred, hundred 50 years.
Honored.
And so that's what I loved about the book.
And it reads like a tourist that's gone
there and kept a journal on in some ways.
I mean,
you made it very clear in the movie,
which you were Nice enough
to show me when that you, um,
you made it really clear that John
Carter was looking to get the hell out of
what we knew as being the world, you know,
he needed to get away from it. I mean,
that was, that was, that was something
we added, um, again, because of the,
one of the downsides of the,
uh,
antiquated nature of the book was that it,
it had very sort of simplistic character
development and some of those things
very quickly became tropes.
They were cool for a while.
When you're doing flash Gordon and uh,
and even early superman and buck
Rogers where you had just the,
the hero that would fight anything and the
Damsel's would go, oh, help me. And uh,
but that was not interesting to us
at all and I wouldn't expect it to be
interested in anybody else.
We took that,
we took sort of these core elements of
them and kept them as starting points.
But if they were any character that
we had been developing in on anything
original and anything else I've worked on,
we would've said it's nowhere near
enough. We need to, we need to, you know,
add a lot more to them. So we, we said,
what if it was more of an origin story
of somebody that had that nature of
fighting for justice no matter
what did they compelled to,
to help others,
but they had gotten bitten really hard
for it and they were afraid to sort of
venture out again to do it. And
that made it interesting. Yeah.
We're running out of power
because the lights are going down.
I think people are turning off their
laptops and maybe it's surging. Yeah.
Um, so, uh, I asked a friend of yours,
well, a colleague of Yours, Rob Cook,
so I don't have any friends.
You don't have any friends?
It's the cost of Hollywood and the
Hollywood. I live up here. Well, I,
you know, I live in mill valley.
I work at Pixar, so that's nice.
The cost of mill valley,
the cost of living in the
Alleles, it's a horrible place.
Uh, no, I'm kidding. My, my wife's
family's from there. Um, so,
so rob cook, uh, who was who, who
just retired after 30 years at Penn?
Yeah. Yeah. I don't know. Um,
so he just retired and he became the
first like concerned Meritus or whatever.
Yeah. That's going to go to his
head. Yeah, it is a, and I said,
is there anything I can ask him that he
hasn't been asked before? He was like,
I don't think so, man. And so I wanted
to talk to you about feet, feet.
So early.
I used to work on games.
And one of the problems of courses
when you would, when you would,
when you would have these
artificial characters, you know,
their feet never looked real.
I see the way the feet and met the
ground never really looked right.
And it's like, and, and you guys
picks her really mastered this.
And then you're thrown into this world
where you have human beings you have to
deal with.
So how did you deal with these?
And you mentioned earlier a little bit
of the trouble of having to deal with
live action and real things and sets
that you'd never done at Pixar. And so,
yeah, it's like, well,
I'm going to try to make a connection
between those two and feet. Um, well,
I don't really like feed that. You know,
the thing he's talking about his weight,
right?
And that's the thing that you see first
time animators make the mistake of all
the time. It's not giving things
proper weight. Um, there's just the,
there's a sense of weight to everything
in the world and whether you're really
conscious effort to not, and
that's, that's what, uh, the, uh,
Disney animators had really
mastered and figured out and we,
and we had sort of pulled from and
John and added to Pixar and definitely,
you know, made that a big deal when we
were, uh, animating on, on this picture.
What a lot of people don't know is that
this movie is got more in a character
animation in it than any other
movie I've ever worked on. Um,
putting the fish movie, including that
fish movie that we will not mention email.
Um, and, uh, it's, um,
it's, so it really was not.
I did and I never swapped one form of
making movies for another. I, I felt like,
oh,
I had to use everything I knew and
then add on top of it a live action,
uh, skills that I had to
sort of learn on the go. Um,
and the big myth,
this even happened on the set I would
get on set on the first couple of weeks
ago.
What's it like to work with people?
Humans like I have never
directed a computer or an
inanimate object in my life.
All I've ever done is to talk to a human
being and I've talked to people that
had to be good at their job,
that had special talents and skills
specifically at whatever they did.
They were great at modeling something,
they were great at lighting something.
They are great at camera.
All of all of them having not only much
more intelligence than me but mostly
more talent in whatever the arena was.
So I was used to debating all the time
and you guys, I don't need to convert.
You get that.
Like if you and I were talking about
where the camera's going to go or what the
model is going to be on a computer, we
can like debate for a couple of minutes,
hours, days about it. Just the,
you know, just, just creatively.
And then you've got to ask the box to
do it and then it becomes this unwieldy
toddler that will not cooperate and not
do what you want and you start banging
on it, you're cursing. And that's
where you run out of time and money.
That's where like everybody thinks
I get it from, I mean I've been,
I'm just coming off of a world tour where
every person that asks from the press
thinks,
well,
what's it like to come from a world
where you can just do whatever you want?
And I'm like, wow, wow.
You have never worked with computers,
have you?
Because I felt like I could get whatever
I wanted on the live action set.
I've never told this story.
This is a good one. Um, the,
the way the way picks are set up is based,
you know, we just made up how we made,
how to make movies. We did it with
our gut and with our instinct.
And I think that helped us. We use logic,
which turns out Hollywood doesn't. And,
and we based it around how
John lasted or work to.
So John always knows what he wants.
I mean,
or at least he's always good at
facilitating how to know what to want and
whether it's micro or macro.
So we built a machine that works
based on how well the director knows.
There's stuff. If the director
doesn't know what what's going on,
the machine doesn't move forward at all.
Um,
and if they really know or they start to
get an idea of the machine moves really
well in live action,
the machine moves whether the director
comes out of his trailer or not.
Which is a real sad that happened to
statement. Well no but, but, but it,
but it was really fascinating.
There'd be days where like,
they're called setups when you're gonna
move the camera to another place and
start a new shot, there'll
be days where like, okay,
we finished that shot and before I could
tell anybody what we were going to do,
they'd all start moving the camera and
putting it somewhere else and I'd play
this little, um, you know, just
functional game of going there.
I'm going to wait and see if anyone's
going to ask me what we're going to shoot
next because they seem to not care. They
seem to be putting it where they will.
I haven't had to talk
that much with Brad Bird,
but we did compare that that was
happening to both of us were like,
is anybody going to ask me what
they want the next shot to be? Wow.
They seem to be fine.
I'm just gonna let them set it up now
and then they'll find out without,
I don't want that camera there.
And um, it didn't happen a lot,
but you started to realize it was,
it was based on just you have to get it
done regardless of if you have an inept
director or the best
director in the world,
they have to work with the
lowest common denominator,
which is really kind of sad. And
uh, but, but they're also bay.
They're there live actions based on,
nobody wants to look bad.
Nobody wants to look like they
weren't ready for any request.
So they're all like on edge, like
whatever he says, whatever. He says,
you know what I do?
And I finally figured that out about three
months into the shoot and we were out
of London in,
in Utah and I'm in this western set that
they've built out in the middle of Utah.
It's fantastic. Is that where the arena
was built? Is that what I was reading?
It's where everything was built, whether
you saw it side and um, and so I'm,
I'm Taylor who is the lead
is walking through a doorway.
It's your classic cowboy coming
into the saloon kind of shot.
And I was feeling like it was a little
too cliche and I had no clue that anybody
had any of these or anything.
I just went,
we need two chickens here
and five minutes, here's
chicken. There were two chickens
and if you see the movie,
you'll see there's two chickens.
And I really didn't need to chickens.
I just at that point wanted to see can
they get three to chicken? And they did.
It was amazing. So, um, I never
wanted to do abuse that privilege,
but it is kind of a,
that's to go back to,
I could get that faster than if I
ever asked for two chickens at Pixar.
Six months would go by and
then we debated, do we really
need to do it? You know,
how should they be model what color
feathers do? My Gosh. And so it's,
that's a long answer from way back
when that question, but two chickens,
that's kind of cool. So we get back to
the question of CGI actors now, right?
CGI actors. So, so one of the
things when rob gave his talk here,
as he talked about how much work you put
into matching was [inaudible] up with
Billy Crystal's mannerisms and the
way he moves his mouth, right? Grass.
And then you have these things with
mouse that are twice as wide. Yes.
And forearms. So they don't
really or not, you know,
the torches are not gonna match
up like that. Nope. They would.
So how did you approach this? Well,
every, to be honest, there's no science.
I mean every, there's a philosophy,
but every single character
do you model every single, uh,
voice you add to it is a different,
uh,
problem to solve.
And it's no different than an actor
being given a new role in another movie.
There's,
there's hopefully something new and
different about it with the same goal of
making you believe that that
character really exists.
So that's part of the thrill.
I mean,
if you don't enjoy trying to figure that
out, that you shouldn't be doing it.
I mean, that's, that's part
of the fun. Um, and, um, I,
you know, all I ever wanted when I read
that book was to believe it. I want it.
I didn't see the world in animation.
I didn't see the world in
cartoons when I was a kid. I just,
when I read something,
I w I was transported,
I was there and I always wanted to
know what it would be like to be on the
surface of Mars and meet
one of these creatures and,
and believe them as much as
I believe anybody else that
I'm talking to right now.
And, uh, when we did a test for
this movie a year in advance,
we made sure our test wasn't flashy,
wasn't jumping around,
it was just two guys talking.
And would I take it as simply as a quiet
moment between butch and Sundance in
the, you know, like, and uh, and
that was the goal because I said,
if we can make that
work, then, then we can,
it's possible to do this film
in the airspace. I want to,
I feel a little frustrated
sometimes because in the marketing,
all they can do is show 15 seconds,
30 seconds,
and it gives the impression that's this
Whizzbang, you know, going to movie.
And it's not, it's, it's,
it's a very much about emotion and
relationships and romance and adventure in
quiet moments. And we're, and that's,
to me what's so sexy about it in a weird
way was the quiet stuff was just the
like, wow, we're, I'm just
really talking to these people.
And I knew to believe that,
that you would fundamentally not only
have to pull what I was used to at Pixar
for the animated characters,
but I'd have to believe the live
action characters as much I can.
I feel like I can tell when an actors
acting against the tennis ball or a green
wall.
Um,
and you can also tell when an actress
does activity against another actor and
they're not getting anything.
Um,
I wanted there to believe that
there was just a real engagement,
a real just in the moment.
So I thought, well,
I have to have great actors up against
great actors, so I need, you know,
somebody that like, uh, willing to
foes stature and Samantha Morton's, uh,
to be willing to play these ultimately
CGI characters because I know what's
going to remain at the end of the
day is their voice, their eyes,
and their movements.
And,
but I also know that none
of that comes for free.
There's been a lot of misdirection
about talking about Mo cap.
Like it's going to actually
do the job for anybody.
It's just a pencil and
it's only as magic fairy.
It's only as good as the
user that uses it. And again,
I'm preaching to the choir here.
You guys all know this.
It's all about who you have,
not what you have.
And I knew that I needed a great
actor on one side and at the back end,
a great animator.
And as long as I had those,
we'd struggle through whatever tools we
thought were the smartest way to work
and what drove the tools we worked
between it was what's going to give me the
most believable presence
on, on, in the actual shot,
while I felt I don't want
it to feel synthetic,
I want to have as much screen real estate,
be real and warm and, and, and, and, uh,
uh, sort of, uh, uh, what am,
what am I thinking of broken and imperfect
and not be cold calculated in video
gamey at the end of the day,
no matter how good it looks,
you can feel a little bit of a separation,
a little bit of coldness when too much
is CGI in a live action combo movies.
So I said, well, to
guarantee that won't happen,
let's actually go to the most
cool desert location we can,
let's actually put the actor in front
of the camera and let's actually put the
other actor that's going to
be CGI in front of the camera.
But because they're nine
foot tall or 10 feet tall,
I need to make sure that the eyes are
going to be exactly what the other eyes
are going to look.
Or else again,
it's going to look like they're not really
looking at each other and they're not
really reacting off of impulse. So I need
these other actors to stand on stilts,
wear gray pajamas with weird head gear
and be like mountain goats and go up and
down like you know these desert hills and,
and that's how I actually sold it
to people like Samantha and Willem.
I said,
how would you like to wear gray pajamas
on stilts and with headgear and being
120 degree heat in the desert?
I figured, why hide it?
And that was literally the first
pitch line I would have to them.
And it was like, it was, it kind of had
this great reverse psychological effect.
There was, it was like a dare.
They were like, really, really?
Nobody's ever dared me to do that before.
I think I'll take it, you know, and,
and, and it worked. And it was,
and they loved it because these,
they've made so many movies, they just
wanted to be challenged again and um,
it was difficult, but nothing effort,
nothing that looks effortless in art,
uh,
is effortless.
It typically is that if it looks
effortless and it looks like it was always
ordained to be that way,
that means a tremendous amount of
inverse effort went into it. Um,
so it was a really difficult
shoot along those lines. Actually,
the relationship that was
expressed in the film between Tar,
starkist and Sola was probably in some
ways the most poignant, right? Yeah. Well,
again, I had willing to phone Smith
more than acting against each other.
I just had to get out of the
way. Did they have a lot of, uh,
did they do a lot of work with your
animators and your folks know it was very
separated,
but the people that were our head
animators are supervising animators that
basically it's trickled down.
They basically are as the guide that
keeps it on track because you always have
multiple animators doing a
single character. You know,
there was 50 animators on Dora yet it
had to come across like w only yelling,
just dreamt, generous seem to be
acting it right. As an example. So, uh,
you have the people that were the
supervising animators, they were on set,
they were on set all the time so that
they could just firsthand be aware of what
was going on. Also be there
when they heard, you know,
what I liked versus what I didn't like.
If we came up with ideas,
we could discuss it and it wouldn't get
lost in the ether. And a year later,
you know,
or actually for me it was like eight
months later when we were suddenly in
animation production,
uh,
we would have a shorthand and
a then that's how it worked.
That's really interesting.
It's funny,
Dory. So we'll have questions, uh, in
near the end of the, of the talk here.
So, uh, you don't want to
line up or anything now,
but if you want to fill it
out and moderator, or if
you want to, uh, go to the,
Mike just made me think of your questions
cause I'm not gonna get all the good
questions, I assure you. Um, so going
from people, the crowds, I mean,
you had some fairly amazing
collection. Yeah. You
know, um, there was, uh,
there were days when I had 500 people
in front of the camera. It was wild.
Um, it was thrilling. I
mean, you can't help but, um,
I would explain to people on days that I
like when, when you had days like that,
when the set was that big or you'd have
an entire air ship that's like on a
gimbal left and right, that took
up a gym, you know, to, you know,
a half a football field or,
or you were out there on the
city street with 500 extras.
Sometimes if you thought too hard about
it, you'd shut down. So I just go,
just pretend it's digital. Just pretend
it's digital. You've worked with worlds.
They're 10 times bigger than this,
you know,
just pretend it's digital and then you
kind of overcome it and you're fine.
All right.
So, uh, Tar Sarkis it's
all, they're all great,
but in some ways I found the most
fun of the movie was in the dog dog,
you know?
Yeah.
He's got the easy job of just
being entertainment. Well, he,
he's that entertaining in the
book if you want to talk about it,
cause I don't want to ruin
the role. I mean, you know,
I don't want to give too much away
about how you meet him, but um, he's uh,
he's basically the equivalent of a dog
or a small bear or something like that
in, in, in a, in this world. Um,
and we tried really hard because there's
so much flora and fauna and so much a
nature that is described in these books
as again, it's, if you had gone there,
right, that we wanted the stuff
not to come across like fanboy.
We didn't want to come across
like this with somebody.
That's been drawing this
character on their, their,
their notebook through school for their
whole life and all they've ever want to
do is just realize it on the screen
since they were 11. Exactly. No,
and we wanted it to, we wanted
it to feel like I'm, no,
this is what nature intended and
this is what nature required, uh,
and evolve to for anything on this planet.
Um,
so we pulled from every kind
of, uh, animal creatures,
sea life, whatever it
was that to, to find a,
a sort of continuity and logistics
behind all the physiology behind every
creature here. Um, but you know what,
let's just a fun, fun character.
I don't know if you're going to show a
clip because if know we're showing a clip
of will. I don't want to, all right.
I still don't want to ruin them.
You'll enjoy Willa. Yeah, he's great.
And it's funny and the reaction of the
audience when it was shown was what it
was just, you could hear the glee,
you know, how they appreciate them.
I want to believe that, you know,
when Burroughs wrote the book,
he had never written anything before.
He was very frustrated with what he was
reading for adventure stories. And I,
and I think he was trying to
read stories to his son and he,
and he just sort of winged it and fit.
And I think you said I could basically
write better than what I'm reading,
you know. And um, and I, I know
weird way I think for doing that,
even though you can look at the
book and find all these in a,
this sort of naive writer and a
lot of things that could be better,
better character development,
maybe some better plotting,
it still holds up because
it's made with such sincerity.
I really feel like somehow he tapped
closer to real myth for being innocent and
unafraid to just jump into it.
And I find a real kinship to that with
what it felt like with being with the
gang. When we first started
making toy story, we,
we didn't know how it was
done with collectively.
We had sort of half the knowledge
you needed. And, um, and,
and that's what really drove
us. Uh, and, and, and I, and I,
I'm so glad we didn't know better or
else we wouldn't have made some of the
glorious mistakes we made that led us
to some of the better answers. And, um,
and so I think that
that's why in a weird way,
there's a lot of elements to his stuff
that holds up today. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
it's funny,
the Pixar nerd in me wants to ask you
like how you would have done Wally
different after doing this, but it
seems like such a Weirdo Wally. No,
nobody's ever asked this.
I'm wildly,
really was a great movie
set up or prep. Yeah.
For me to do this movie,
because it was all about imperfection.
It was all about trying to figure out
how to make them for Wally make it feel
like you just discovered this guy
and life with this life was going on,
whether you documented it or not.
And so it is a sad thing that when
you do an all computer graphics movie,
nothing comes for free. You have
to plan everything. So we were,
we had to plan for imperfection.
We had to break down and deconstruct
what tells you that you're using a camera
because of the imperfection in the Lens.
What tells you that a human being's
holding the camera because of the inertia
and the muscle fatigue.
What tells you that you're working within
an actual space that's really tiny and
you have to change your,
your,
your choices of how your camera work is
because you're stuck in the corner with
the camera.
Like all of that stuff was planned.
You don't get any of that for free.
So anything that felt kind
of gritty and imperfect, uh,
in any of our movies,
let alone that one was planned,
which can drive you insane.
Um,
and but I knew that that was the thing
to embrace and try to capitalize on and
again own.
But I get a lot more for free for shooting
a in the conditions that we shot for
Carter.
So that again,
it would feel like this is probably
really happening somewhere.
So like real so,
so it's funny cause so thank God I made
Wally before it or I wouldn't have had
that instinct. Yeah. Now you can sort
of in some ways, and I know that,
uh, up was not so much
yours, but you know,
you can sort of trace this sort of like
animals, that Pixar sorta thing really.
And I sort of in some weird way,
maybe it's me and that's okay. Um,
but you know, where you see,
you know, animals like Doug,
I look to Molly and all the
rest of, you know, leading
the things like, right. Yeah.
So, so that you can see like there's a
history there and you sorta want to, well,
it's a natural instinct.
It's a much more natural instinct for an
animator to give life to something that
isn't human, right. Because it's just,
I, it's just how you're wired up. I mean,
humans, do you have the
exact example? Exact example.
They're right. They're right.
And when I was in, uh, you know,
I grew up in this small town where there
wasn't as many kids like me that liked
all the exact same thing. We were all sort
of, you know, smaller minority game on,
you know, Andrew's. Yeah. And, um,
so it wasn't until I went to college for
animation that I met other kids of my
tight and that I realized
that I was a type like, oh,
you also thought your
bike was cold in the rain,
that a fish was lonely in the fishbowl.
That of leaf was afraid of
heights when it fell. You know,
I couldn't stop myself from
looking at things like that.
That was just the way I
always looked at the world.
And so imbuing animals and
inanimate objects with things is,
is sort of like a, I don't know,
animation one-on-one. Yeah, I bet. I bet.
Now it's funny because, so one of
the questions that I mentioned, uh,
like you should ask him
about how he did if for
these guys and stuff.
But I want that and I want you to tell
us about that because that's always
really interesting for, for
me. Uh, and me again. Uh,
but the thing that really struck me when
I was watching the film is I was trying
to find the things that were
truly alien. Right? Yeah.
Because whenever people do alien
worlds, different worlds, unfortunately,
sometimes they're awfully, you
know, us Los Angeles looking thing.
Oh really? But, um, but for me, the,
the flying machines and the
interfaces and the interface,
the interface to use that
word, I'm so sorry. Uh, so,
but the interface for controlling
that flying machine, you know,
you have this fellow from, you know, you
know, they're just coming out of the, the,
the war, you know, and
something he's presented with
having to fly this thing. Yes.
You have to figure it out. Yeah. I mean,
how much did you work on making that? Oh,
it was so fun.
I worked with basically
two people, uh, on all the,
all the props and the machines
and stuff. It's, again,
those are described in the books,
not down to their detail,
but to their major functions.
And stuff. Um, it was with the,
my production designer,
Nathan Crowley,
who works on all of Christopher Nolan's
movies, most of them. And uh, and um,
Brian Church who is an incredible concept
artist and a who had ironically worked
on other, uh, failed, uh, attempts to
put a princess of Mars onto the screen.
And,
uh,
we finally came around to it and I just
kept saying without knowing what I was
looking for in the very beginning,
I just want it to be a period film
of a period I didn't know about.
I just want it to look like we researched
our marsh and history and did really,
really well. I want it to be
in historical costume drama.
I want it to feel like the satisfaction
you get when you go, oh, this is my,
what be what it was like
to be an ancient Egypt.
This is might be what it was
like to be in feudal Japan. And,
and even though nobody knew
that this existed before.
So we did a lot of discussion that when
Burroughs wrote this book and when he
kind of places the time of things on
earth, it was pre industrial revolution.
And what does that really mean?
Well,
it means pre automization for a lot
of things or even the stuff that was
automated, it was so rudimentary, you
could look at it and figure it out.
You had the luxury of just seeing
how everything was connected,
how they're all the gears were attached
and it usually still required a lot of
manpower. And so that's very visual.
That's very cinematically friendly.
So we said let's make it in depth
preindustrial revolution on Mars.
Um, I kept saying tall
ships in the sky. Yeah. Um,
when you look at tall ships, I don't know.
I still, I mean my father's not a call.
I've been out on boats most of my life
and I still can't figure out half of what
a tall ship does, but I can look at it
and know that everything I'm looking at,
you know, the rigging, the Wa, the
ropes and all the gears and the wood.
And I could tell that like
they all have a function and,
and that's very kind of, um, satisfying.
I mean it's very cool. You, you feel a lot
of history and depth and, and of, of, of,
of, uh, learning that has
happened to, to get to that,
that vessel to that point.
And that's what we decided to do
with everything on Mars was, uh,
make it feel that you
could see the manual labor,
see all the purpose and the function
and culture behind everything.
And then one of the brain teasers was,
if we want to make it feel that
this has been concurrently going on,
then how do we,
how do we not let it accidentally look
like earth had anything to do with it?
Because in other words, if you suddenly
saw a doorknob on a door, you'd be like,
Earth, Earth lame. You know, and
suddenly you're down to like, okay,
I'll look at the Burbank.
Yeah. Fundamentally. How to,
how did they come up with windows? How
did they come up with doors? And you know,
it was hard,
but it was so satisfying to come up
with those answers because again,
none of that stuff's ever pointed out.
It's never,
there's never a spotlight on it. But
if you've done it right, you feel it.
I learned a lot of that from just making
worlds at Pixar. I'm like, there's, again,
not in a single detail gets on
the screen without planning it.
So I'm used to over planning and making
sure that everything in the mid ground
background had a reason and whether
it ever gets addressed or not.
And so that really paid off also for a
film like this, sort of like Andy's room,
but Mars, yeah. Auntie's room. But
Mars, wow, here's the sales pitch.
Here's the sales pitch. I'm
not, but so the language,
which sort of dominates his
relationships with them, you know,
sort of mid movie Red Way Ish,
you know, earlier. Yeah. Yeah.
But you obviously put an awful
lot of work into it. I mean, well,
break your heart to go all Babel
juice on it. I mean, you know,
Burroughs did a lot of that. I
mean, he had written 11 books, uh,
of this series by 1960.
And so when I was a kid in 1976 and
found this book at 11, it was already,
it was already done. It was
my Harry Potter. I mean, I,
there were so many adventures and you
could just tell the desire to keep
discovering places that hadn't been mapped
on the, on the, on, on the, on the, uh,
on the world, on the globe was really
what drove each book. It was like, oh,
we didn't know about this part of the
world. We didn't know about this country,
didn't know about these people.
And you,
and you travel with this little group
that we all meet in the first one and over
11 books. That's a lot of Martian
language that he had slowly compiled.
And fortunately, I, it's
called a guide to Barsoum.
Somebody in late sixties early seventies
took the pains and never left their
basement and put it all together in an
encyclopedia. This is before we keep him.
So I think we bought every
copy of it for off Ebay.
Everybody in the art department,
Production Really? And a,
yeah, and we were able,
it was half my work done for me.
I mean that's usually two years at Pixar
working on something is coming up with
that stuff and it still wasn't full
languages. It was only like he wasn't,
he never thought about it from like
this wide about how it all connects,
but it was enough information that
we could give it to a linguist.
We gave it to a guy named Paul from or
who actually did all the languages for
Avatar.
And at first I was a little reluctant
because I didn't want to look redundant,
but then it turned out to be the smartest
thing because he didn't want to be
redundant. And so he wanted to
go a whole nother direction.
And also he had a book that
already had a starting point.
He had to work in this pool that
burrows had set. And so, um,
and the whole movie, you know, it
doesn't work in Martian language.
It only works for maybe a quarter of a
movie. So, uh, it really works out great.
The, the, I, I don't know if this
would thrill than anybody else,
but one of the most
thrilling moments for me,
we had a week to a week and a half before
we started shooting where we called it
the dark camp, um, where we taught the
actors that were going to play Sarcs,
how to walk on stilts,
how to work with Mocap,
how we were going to shoot specific
things and functions that they had to do
with, uh, within certain scenes
and how to learn the language.
So they worked with a,
a language coach and they had all their
lines read to them on us on a CD so that
they could play it back all the time,
uh,
from Paul Fromer for they
get the pronunciation right.
And so they sat in a circle once,
a twice a day,
and they would talk back and forth
to each other with their lines, uh,
even though they didn't actually
functionally have a column response.
And then what the meanings behind the
lines where they were just to be able to
look each other in the eye and talk and
get more used to hearing how each other
talk and they start adopting the
same accent. And it was the cool,
it was the animator and me.
It was the coolest thing is the
first time I heard Polly Walker,
Thomas Haden Church, uh, Willem Defoe and
Samantha Morton all talk to each other.
And I didn't look and I could
tell exactly who was who and I,
that's when I knew we were in good hands
that we'd have no problem being able to
follow who was who in the movies. So, so,
so as I'm watching this
and I kept on saying, well,
with the exception of a Darryl's
Hybris character, right?
It seems like it would sort of break
your heart as you're going through it,
as you're building this over what,
four years you worked on this by five
years you keep on leaving behind things
like you leave behind the language,
you'll leave behind Bryan Cranston and
now it's like you leave behind all these
people and you really,
you have these core people of course,
who you carry through the whole movie,
but it doesn't it kill you to say, oh,
we're not going to visit that
language again until the next move.
A real nice problem to have. I mean, it
must be, yeah, that's what the books were.
Yeah. We tried to, again, I don't
want to be called hidebound.
I approached all of this.
I don't think I made a single
career choice on this thing.
It was all about wanting to finally
see after 36 years as a fan,
this thing up on the screen.
Right.
And hoping that it would start a snowball
that would start a series that would
go as many movies, if not
more as the books, which would
weigh outlive me. I mean,
I can't, I have, there's no way
anybody can promise that'll happen,
but that's your hope. So you
have to plan for that. So I plan,
we got the rights to the first
three books and we mapped it out,
Michael Mark and I like a good TV
season so that everything has a Meta
underlying goal with it.
And also not being able to be
afraid to like hold something back.
That might've been
great in the first book,
but we couldn't find a
narrative excuse for right.
And use it in the second or it'll come
up in the third with a much grander
purpose.
And the same thing about pulling somebody
or something from one of the later
books and put it in earlier and
have the competence and comfort of knowing
there's a grand design that this will
all satisfy, uh, if we, if we can keep
going. But I also hate cliffhangers.
I hate being left in the dust right
before. I hate the Hubris of like, oh,
we'll definitely be back. You know, I
just, I just, I just find that cocky,
but Groupons and I'm still frustrated
from buckaroo. Banzai well,
thank you. And, and I mean,
I want, I'm still waiting.
Yeah. You know, playing a 10.
So it was a little of what it was.
How do you,
how do you let it so that it
can continue on if you want,
but you've been emotionally satisfied
and come to a conclusion at the end of
each of these stories.
For us,
it's a trilogy and each of
these have a very wrapped up,
complete narrative emotional
statement that we're doing,
but there are greater things that
will go on if we're allowed to. So,
so if you want to start
lining up to ask questions,
now's a great time to do that. Um, uh,
because I really only have one
question that I, I'm just dying to ask.
So consequence.
So you said,
you mentioned that at your Ted talk in
a way that basically without consequence
there is no drama, right? Yep. And
unfortunately as I've gotten older, uh,
you come to say,
well,
it's extremely unlike the John Carter
is going to die in this movie, right?
It's extremely unlikely the data
tourist is going to die this movie.
So is there really a consequence?
How do you,
how do you sort of try
to pull out that drama?
I don't want to give away anything,
but you know,
the whole time you're watching it, he
goes back to Earth. Yeah, that's true.
That was part of the narrative
structure. Yeah. So, uh, please
ask,
you're making decisions as a director,
how do you conceptualize the audience
of your mind? Is it, is it yourself?
Is it your 11 year old?
Exactly. No, that's it. I mean,
I've been asked this question
for 25 years now, 22 years,
and I got mad at the press recently.
I just said, my Gosh, you know,
I'm going to answer this
the same way in five years,
in 10 years and 15 years of the same way
I've been answering for the last 20. Uh,
I don't think about who the audience is.
I think about the audience.
If I'm ever thinking of the audience,
it's the audience member and myself,
like I can't, I disassociate
myself and go, okay,
I'm going to the theater and I'm going
to go see this, would I like this?
But that's the most I would ever
ask from anybody that I love.
That's an artist that I follow.
I'm not sitting there hoping that
Scorsese's tried to second guess my
demographic or tried to test anything or
the Picasso ever did though the Beatles
or the stones. I follow them because
I find them to be the tastemakers.
I find them to be the people that they
can see farther past the horizon than I
can. And I want to know what
they're getting into that I'm,
I'm not clear on yet. And, and that's,
that's always been obvious to me
that that's what I, I somehow,
because movies are these big things with
armies behind them and lots of money
and a lot of anxiety from a studio,
uh,
it starts involving the
audience and I just feel it.
That's the kiss of death. Um,
and we've never followed
it at Pixar. And Steve got
that from the beginning. So he,
he really is credit.
I always got to get more credit than I
ever do about how much he just firewall
does from everything and just let us do,
make all the mistakes,
all the gut instincts that we would have
done had we never left home and just
we're making this thing for ourselves.
Anything we've made, I've made so far.
Knock on wood, I could care less. I've
ever get to show it to anybody else.
I've satisfied me and maybe the people
that I care about peer wise artistically
and that has stood us in such good stead
were superstitious now of ever doing
anything more than that.
So,
and I would never want anybody
else to do differently.
I just find it's a little
disrespectful of the audience.
It's like Steve had a great saying,
which is it's our job to know what people
want before they do and I think that's
incredibly ballsy and
incredibly insightful.
Is that really hard to instill
in the people you work with?
Some those coming from the rest?
Not at all, no. The Hollywood,
I find that really artistic people get it.
People that don't, I don't really care.
Okay.
I'm glad to hear
you mentioned, you know, you as an artist,
you have to kind of go about your vision
and then kind of see, uh, you know,
once it's out in the world, what people
think of it. Do you ever get into,
you mentioned that the
previous or John Carter,
you may not accurately reflect kind
of what your concept is for the movie.
Do you ever have a,
you know,
Journal dialogues with marketing
folks or how did you go about,
how do you get to crying like a,
it's not,
I've never worked on a movie that was easy
to sell unless it had a two behind it.
And so it's, it's, I've, I've had,
I've, I've said to mark and I said,
just get used to, it's never going to
be easy. You're going to get, you know,
silent robots, rats that cook, you know,
Octogenarians with a Korean boy scouts,
romantic adventures that are from 1912.
I mean it's,
it's not going to be easy for
you get used to it because
people always say to the marketers
and to the studios what they want.
They want the door knob. But the truth is,
is that they don't know what they want.
They're,
all they are capable of
doing is describing what they
liked last because they're
searching.
But what they really want is a new color
that won't be as cool as the last color
they had saw and they don't know
how to describe that new color.
That's our job.
And the marketer said job is to
say it looks exactly like orange,
but it won't look like orange. It's a
tough job for them. I'm not trying to get,
you know, get them off, you know, off
the hook. But I get it. It's, I mean,
I've had nothing but full cooperation.
I just get the W it's tough. I mean,
I know that once they're in the theater,
they'll go, oh, I always wanted this.
I just didn't know it.
You know? And that's the,
that's the feeling I want when
I see or hear something, it's,
it's just you're in this weird betwixt
and between prior to to release of
anything. Cool. Thanks. Cool.
Hi. So first of all, I'm a big fan of
the fish movie, so thank you for that.
I don't say it,
I don't know.
Why can't we say that it
finding Mimo, right? It's,
it's like the movie that must
not be exactly what we call this,
the finding Voldemort, the Mars
movie. I, you know, anyway,
so speaking of marketing,
um,
so the book is a princess of Mars.
And when I first started
hearing about the movie,
it was John Carter of Mars
and now it's John Carter.
And I know there's obviously a lot of
people in a lot of factors that go into
the title of the movie.
And I was wondering if you could talk
about how that evolved in this case.
I'm at a place now where I'll ruin the
movie if I tell you exactly what I,
why I finally came up with
the decision that I did,
but there was a real sort of testing
that went on with groups and stuff that I
couldn't ignore that,
uh,
about the title that happened last year
where they found that a large portion of
people, and this is again the wrong
place to say it's too, don't like sigh.
I think they don't like Scifi or think
they know what Scifi means when they hear
that word. And the Mars thing was
just boom. It was like saying, um,
will you watch a movie with subtitles?
I don't like to read. I won't see it.
And you just know the,
how many movies you've done,
been denied of what you might enjoy.
You know,
had you just got over that Hump and then
she didn't showed subtitles from the
Mars. Shaun's um, I can't,
I couldn't ignore that fact. And so,
but then nobody was making me change it.
It was more like, well, how do we want
to deal with this? So I slept on it for,
I dunno, a week and I started
to realize, you know what,
just from a narrative
storytelling standpoint,
it's about John Carter and I,
and then I had this idea that
I pitched to Disney. I said,
if you'll let me have it the way I'd
like when they leave the theater and then
I'll be willing to go the
way that everybody would
feel more comfortable going
into the theater because of Mars is not
going away and it's going to be an every
other title if it ever comes
back. So that was really, it
came down to it. So we'll
see. Thank you. Thanks.
Um,
hi there.
So I'm a huge fan of Pixar and one thing
I really love about the movies I've
seen is it's more than just a fun story,
but there's always a bigger meaning
behind them. Like, for example,
maybe it was just me that saw this
or it's all in my head. But um,
like cars for example,
I saw like I saw situations there that
reflected the economy or about how up has
some concepts of like materialism in that.
Yes.
Is that something that you purposely
think of early on when you're coming up
with these stories?
I think I can pretty much say of though,
I can't speak for every
filmmaker that at Pixar that no,
because we're so emotionally driven,
but we love that anything that starts
to create parallels or feel like it does
naturally link up to truths that are
out there, whether they're economic,
political or emotional.
Great.
Let's use them because you just want
it to feel that much more grounded.
The last thing any of us want to do or
like having done to us as being preached
when we watch a movie,
um,
I think you want to feel something and
if that turns out to be connected to a
deep truth that you are inspired by,
again,
politically or environmentally were great.
But what matters to us is
that you're touched here,
not here more than anything else.
Um,
it's also just the curse of I'm the guy
that likes the music and then I don't
even know what the lyrics were
for years, you know. Oh, you know,
that's about incest. What? I had no idea
coming in that tomb for years, you know.
Um, somebody just showed me the lyrics
come my Sharona and they're awful.
They're horrible. I had no
idea. So, but, uh, anyway,
I know my little pretty thank you.
Sure.
Please play full rounded off.
I'm sorry. Got It. Oh, sorry.
Yeah, thanks for coming.
I think, I think Wally's actually
one of my favorite Pixar movie.
You think you're gonna hear that
a lot and I just had a question.
I hope it doesn't offend anyone
at Pixar or you, but, uh,
it just seems like since Disney is like
petting, like, no, he has acquired eight.
It's, it seems like Pixar is now
be trying to book some being other,
more commercial, like for example, Bait.
They suspended production on newt to
focus on cars too. And No, it's just,
you worry that there's a tension there.
The sts, cause like, you know, that's,
you guys perceiving it. Uh,
it's, it's, it's, it's more
scrutinized now. Okay. There's,
we had other projects that we've
killed that we spent years on.
We just weren't so publicly.
The world is so exposed and transparent
now and everybody cares and everybody's
watching.
We could've,
we could've announced to the high heavens
all the things we killed in the first
10 years and nobody would
have listened. Um, so
yeah,
also again,
if I've learned one thing about human
beings for having to study them,
so specifically for writing is that
we're born to be conspiracy theorists
and we hate that we can't
make patterns out of things.
And we hate that we can't
connect the dots. And, uh,
we do it without even trying.
And I can promise you that there is
okay.
Maybe this is too much to say,
but some of my favorite things
of Pixar are yet to come.
So great. Thanks for reassuring
this. Sure. I don't think
that's too much to say.
I mean it's pretty, I don't
want to be cocky. Alright.
So one final question. We got it from
the, the livestream actually. Um,
it references your, your Ted talk that
you did just a few days ago. Oh, okay.
They're,
they're asking you to explain
the difference between
making the audience to work
for their meal and making them feel what
you want them to feel and perhaps tie
that into the work you
did for John Carter.
Well, it's just story. It's
the basics of storytelling
it, which is, um, you know, I,
I had this, this, this, this theory
for a while from toy story on once we,
you know, toy story sort of left us
with this like, wow, did we do that?
And there was a lot of time spent sort
of looking back and, and analyzing and
Rican and deconstructing what,
what the hell did we do? And uh,
and we used to curse that movie
all the time. We're like, Damn,
we made that movie too good because it
made us have to, we had to, you know,
still would buzz light year.
We had to keep the bar up to that every,
and you know, it's actually a
blessing, not a curse, but man,
does it make your life hard?
Yeah.
One of the things I remember starting
to get a discovery of a four now seeing
the behind the scenes of making a movie
is I could go back and look at all my
favorite movies and with a different eye,
a little bit better understanding of
why did I like all these other movies so
much? And um, and I realized that, um,
that you're always problem solving,
that you're always in a, in,
in good hands being asked to
sort of, uh, hold this thought,
put that together,
wait and see where that's going to go.
And it's all very orchestrated and,
and um,
you were actually working for your meal,
but it's done in such an entertaining
and engaging way. You don't know it.
And that was what I finally concluded
was that audiences want to work for the
meal. I just don't want to
know that they're doing.
Yeah. So along those lines as
we're wrapping up, um, but yes, I,
I apply that Don Carter apply
that on everything that I
do. Sorry. That's fine. Uh,
so help us cheat on this work, right.
Not by giving us a spoiler or anything,
but like the chickens,
everyone who goes to see John Carter who's
seen this now it's gonna look for the
chickens. Right, right. And, and I'm,
I'm thinking about too, when I saw it,
cause I didn't have the pre knowledge
of the chickens. I'm like, why?
Because it didn't seem different than the
standards for guy walks into a bar and
gets punched out. Kind of. Yeah. Right.
I'm not, that's what happened. But anyway.
Um, is there, is there a
direction you want them to,
to have in mind?
Is there something you want them to think
about when they're watching the movie?
No.
My hope is mommy to go hope is seriously
because we tried so hard to capture
what it felt like.
Not only to read the book,
what it felt like to see so many great
movies in the 70s when I was a kid. Yeah.
There's no for knowledge. Oh, exactly.
We knew nothing. I mean, it was,
I look back and I realized how lucky I
was that I didn't know anything before I
saw any of what are
considered these great movies.
We just all went to the movie theater,
pay their money, walked, sat down,
and were surprised.
And when I think about how much surprise
everybody is denied now kids are denied
now. It makes me real
sad. It makes me, it.
They're never going to know what it
was like to just go and discover.
And it's the most glorious
feeling. It really is. And,
and I just wanted to,
the best we could do,
make you be swept away in the
same romantic adventure way that,
that we were with not only the book,
but, but the movies of that time.
And I've shown trailers for things
like a alien. And so honestly,
in a weird way,
I almost wonder if it's a blessing in
disguise that the trailer's really given
you what
it's like, because maybe you'll be
that much more surprised, you know,
in a good way. Okay. Well thank you
so much for coming and thank you.
[inaudible].